meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zu wer weiß mehr unser
nächster gast ist schon auf dem weg
hierhin ins studio er muss sich gerade
und auch frisch machen weil jetzt geht
es um kopf und kragen
eine unverschämtheit
ja wir haben das quiz viele nutzer ist
zuschauer beschweren sich darüber die
fragen sind so schwer aber sie müssen
schwer sein weil sonst wäre es nicht
weiß wer also heute wer weiß mehr zum
thema matze knop du hast dich lange auf
dieses vorbereitet nicht weil mein
spezialgebiet aber ich versuche was geht
ok wird also meine lieblingsfigur ist ja
oder einer deiner klassiker ist der
franz beckenbauer und der twittert seit
kurzem ja nicht nur oliver kahn ein
aufgerichteter über ich auf meine
follower
6700 euro
auf jetzt kommt aber wie viele follower
hat franz beckenbauer
also weniger 20.000 b mehr als 35.000 t
mehr als 70.000 oder dem er als eine
million
ich sage er hat weniger als 20 euro du
sagst du willst wirklich jetzt schon ein
ende der krise man muss immer nachdenken
ja man kann also schaut man muss ja und
das machen was die eigene stärke ist und
das ist leider ein stelldichein lieber
spontan ohne nachzudenken also loks
einig locker ich bin auch einer von den
verfolgern übrigens ok wurde ich bin
auch einer von den weniger als man sich
das ok ich glaube ja ich glaube der hat
gerade erst angefangen deswegen könnte
das stimmt wahrscheinlich ist ein
bisschen mehr mittlerweile aber deswegen
lass mich noch mal kurz überlegen
wir wollen das auch nicht ganz
b ja also weniger als 20.000 bei mehr
als 35.000 c mehr als 70.000 dann kommt
nochmal märz um fast
das 1
und es ist richtig
womit bewiesen wäre spontanes antwort
ist nicht deine stärke das ist wohl
richtig deswegen habe ich auch noch mal
überlegt sehr gute was eigentlich jetzt
nicht meine stärke war man in denen sich
arbeiter werden ich habe bis jetzt nur
6600 was ist da los freuen es gibt leute
dass ich
bin der falsche becken und ich sage dir
natürlich ließ zu oft verkleidet lustig
öfters okay gut öfter mal material dann
einfach du selbst sein der auch nicht
hinter logan etwas verstecken noch drin
doch wir waren sicher
mehrere was wir hier haben wir haben ja
mehr
wir fragen über fragen
radio bielefeld
sendet auf der frequenz 98 3 erst mal
die haben 98 3 b 93 18 89 3d
100,4 manchmal nicht montanes antworten
doch nicht so schlecht also geboxt ein
ja hallo hoffmanns drei freunde und die
97.6 glaube ich für die randgebiete aber
das stand ja nicht zur disposition
wie viele wochen hätte hielt sich super
richie in den single charts noch in den
top 10 19
24 b 36 c 48 oder
72 10
2010 rechtzeitig den finanzen
leisten das ist nahe
mein partner
die zweitlängste
krankheiten
sag mal blog
und es wieder richtig wenn das der
kapellmeister den großen tisch bitter
für mich
jetzt trifft es natürlich warum meine
reifen einigen klicks haben da mitunter
feierlich überreichen den musst du jetzt
immer tragen jetzt waren es 19
19 womit man hier
einen treuen traurige wochen in den
deutschen album-charts natürlich hier
noch einmal 19 jahre alt
ja wir könnten noch 20 jahren erst noch
nicht hat ist jetzt kaufen dann war es
zu spät
kaufen kaufen
und ihr einen holzschrank das sofort
drei sätze heute ist es nicht mehr
erinnern